[Music]
okay everybody I am so so thrilled today
because I am joined by Ruth Cod AKA Anya
in the Midnight Club which is out now on
Netflix we're gonna be talking spoilers
about the show so make sure you watch
the whole show first before we watch
this interview Ruth how you doing today
good thanks for having me it's I still
find it so weird they're like she's in a
show on Netflix that's out now yeah this
must be surreal for you and especially
because Netflix puts you right in the
public eye of like everybody
internationally so it's got to be crazy
this week for you right oh well like I
mean I don't have that much star power
like no one really knows I'm still you
know still very much able to go to the
supermarket
um I was in an airport yesterday and I
was like well maybe someone might you
know right close now
talk to me in two weeks because that's
gonna change so what's interesting
though is you do have a little history
with Fame so you used to be a former
Tick Tock star and I'm wondering what
talk to me about the transition like
what made you want to kind of leave that
and go more into acting oh god well I
use the firm term Fame very loosely
during the pandemic I was unemployed I
had no money and moved back with my
parents I mean like everyone I was bored
out of my brains so I started to tick
tock
and like a lot of things in my life just
by accident it it blew up so I got a
message from
uh engine casting and from Annie and
Morgan and they they said
have you ever acted before and I was
like no I was like well I did actually
that's all I did play villager number
four and let's go play
um
um but they they sent me the audition
they were like give it a go and I did
expecting
for them to never ever get back to me
and I was like that's going to be used
as blackmails that footage
um
and I I got it and here I am so was that
your first audition ever like is it the
first time you're doing anything like
that
yeah that was my first ever um audition
you just like they gave you the script
and my mum did kind of turn into Steven
Spielberg when we were doing uh
I'd get like a word on she's like nope
take it back
um
so it took me ages to do the audition
because took me ages to learn how to
memorize the lines
um
so yeah that was my first ever
audition and that's kind of how you
audition now because I always taught
auditions were like you go into a room
with loads of really judgmental people
and they're like
um and I've yet to experience that can't
wait so no yeah you definitely got the
better gig with the zoom auditions for
sure and also did you know what your
audition for like did you know it was
gonna be this Mike Flanagan big Netflix
project like did you already have
pressure even going into the audition
like that
I mean no pressure like so nothing to
lose
um I knew who who Mike Flanagan was
obviously because I love her
um
and I love like Hill houses like
jailhouse so much
so I didn't I actually didn't the name
didn't ring a bell at me and I actually
only looked up
him up after I'd sent it in and then I
was like oh [ __ ]
I was like oh [ __ ]
oh my God so so in that though knowing
that knowing who it is knowing you're a
fan of his work and then you're talking
about the auditioning but also for
people who probably are shocked hearing
this right now that this is your first
acting role so what was that like being
on set being on this big set and your
first time jumping into this thing was
that terrifying
no I mean I was in this wonderful
conversation where I just nothing to
lose and I'm like if they fire me they
still have to pay me so it's like
I love that you're you're very smart now
I'm gonna jump into this story now in
this character value which is just
amazing characters my favorite character
on the show so
when you were first reading the script
though what did you read about Anya that
you definitely knew in your head you
wanted to get down right like what were
you like lasered in on about her
I even during for the audition it was
the scene in episode 2 where she has a
go to Lanka for pitying Spence and
giving him the look
and I immediately
related to that straight away because
the the worst thing about having my
injury at 15 was people treated me
differently and they paid and I hated it
and I hate and it was that there was
there's a look they don't have to say
anything but there's there's a look so
uh
I relate a lot to Anya's cat like to
have just disappointed she is
and how angry it makes her
um you know a lot like Anya I used to
take it out on my my family too
um
so I I just I understood where
immediately I understood where she was
coming from uh yeah and I totally love
that point you made about that look and
that feeling of just pity people get and
it's interesting too because you brought
up with that episode two the two Dana's
which is a great episode and we get to
see Anya do her story now with prime
Dana and Dana too did you play them as
just extreme versions of Anya like
opposite versions and how challenging
was it to have your own self as a scene
partner
oh I mean it was my I think I've been
acting four days when we started to film
that
and I was like I walked in one day I was
like oh I was like I'm gonna this is
this is a lot
um
but it I had so what they do is so
there's me and then I'll have a body
double at least so Elisa sticks say the
lines and
um for say if I'm doing a one she'll say
the lines for Dana too and she's such a
brilliant actress that it gave me
something to bounce off of so it she
made it so easy for me and as well you
think kind of they'd film it in a way
that you're Dana won for the day and
then the next day you're down to two
going like back and forth back and forth
back and so I was my tiny little brain
was
the little monkey on it was like yeah
I love that
so did you have more fun playing Dana
one or Dana too
Dana's here is psychopath so I had so
much fun like create I wanted to make
them both different because they're two
aspects for personality and
so I wanted to make both difference but
it was so much fun like so much fun with
Elise because I would have been
lost there would not have been an
episode too they would have just been
like it's going straight to episode
three without her oh you have her to
thank for that for that
that's amazing so yeah and that episode
is awesome episode and also too when we
first meet Anya you know she's tough
she's very cold at first she's got
standoffish part about her but
you do a great job but also there's
always like this underlying likability
Humanity about her and that's a props to
your betrayal of her was there a
conscious effort for you though not to
go too far at first with like kind of
the harshness Anya was giving like was
there a sweet spot you had to find
no I think
the further you take it I mean I have to
say she's a teenager she's a teenage
girl and as we all know teenage girls
are worthless so
um no I never
was conscious about making her
anyway like about the first two episodes
because she's not she's she's mean and I
took it as far as as I could
um because
yes she's it's not coming she's the type
of person that has I think at the very
heart she's a good heart and it's coming
from a place of where she wants to
protect her friends their own hospice
and she doesn't want them to get there
you know it takes a long time to accept
something like that and she doesn't
to have false hope and
but it doesn't it's it's like real life
it doesn't always come across the people
are coming from a good place
and I think it takes a couple of
episodes to realize oh she was coming
from a good place she does have a heart
and but you know it's like real life
where sometimes it might take you a
while to to warm up to someone and to
realize they're not you know a total
[ __ ] yeah I was like what word is
she gonna say okay
I love that that build up so but in that
journey of any though and as we see
in her Arc
going back to episode the end there
episode two with the two Danish what do
you think Anya was
trying to reveal to the rest of the club
about herself whether it was consciously
or subconsciously at that point with
that story
I think he in a way
that whole story is probably about her
wishing she had a do-over
um about everything oh she didn't
realize what she had when she had it and
she kind of threw it all away and I'm
you know with the episode I'm like this
I'm not spoilers I'm not oh all spoilers
let's go yeah yeah and then with that
moment where Along Came five where she
really where she reveals that she did
actually
you know Aaron's stats was her fault and
so
I think a lot of the two Danish was
revealing
in a better self but again because it's
on you she won't ever say it directly
she'll kind of leave them wondering like
what part of that story were real what
parts were and she'll always kind of
leave it open to interpretation
yeah I I love that answer that's great
and yeah you're right too because a lot
of the show too you're trying to figure
out what's real what's happening or
where we even are and I felt that my
favorite episode I'm not just saying
this but episode said Anya uh
heartbreaking but
I'm wondering because I was reading read
discussions about the episode and people
already kind of debating like where we
actually are in that episode some people
saying I saw some people saying
Purgatory but
and then most people were saying though
is this coma dream leading to her
hearing the club outside her door how
did you read that where exactly were at
a given time in that episode
um well again that's the beautiful thing
about Mike's work is that
it's always open to interpretation and
you know and
that's the thing about like ours just
gonna make something like such like one
of the most artistic ourselves but
that's like the characters that you
never the beauty of it is never knowing
the answer really and it's always just
your interpretation of it and and my
interpretation of it
is you know
um that she's she's in she's in the coma
and she's having you know it's really
dark because even in her
dream life where everything works out
she's still miserable all right
it's sad because I feel like she thinks
she doesn't almost deserve to be happy
and then her friends come and they're
like no no you do deserve to be happy
and this is what this is how it would
work out you know yeah for sure and
that's I guess what makes it even more
heartbreaking and I think also too my
favorite performance you had in this
show was in this episode when Anya is on
the phone with Rhett so blown away by
that level of just passion you put in
there anger sadness how did you get to
that place as an actress was that also
wild for you is that a moment you kind
of just Lose Yourself
it's it's it's weird because you can
prepare
as much as you want and then on the day
everything goes out the window and you
can
I just as an actress I'll never put
pressure on myself
to to cry or or to feel a certain thing
I'll just do it on the day
and and and try my best with it and
I mean yeah I I you know I related
a lot there's something that happened in
my life that
um
it made that scene in particular did
make me
I related to it a lot and someone not
really wanting to know you anymore and
there was a lot of I think I
I didn't mean to on the day but I think
there was a lot of like anger in the pit
of my stomach that I I down the phone I
was like not talking to Red I was like
talking to someone yeah yeah that's what
I was wondering yeah because I'm like it
was more impressive too that you were
doing it on the phone so yeah and that
that makes sense so you felt like it was
coming somewhere from within there was a
connection to your soul in that there's
a funny story about that actually
um the ad Mark the first ideas so I
didn't have Daniel
um on the other end of the phone I had
the ad Mark in the room reading Daniel's
lines okay and anyone who knows Mark is
he's the most dead pan human he's the
probably one of the funniest people I've
ever met but like he's just
Monitor and he was like
you know it's kind of meant to be
dramatic getting in the you know getting
into it and he was there and he was like
Anya
Anya please Anya and I'm like I'm like
[ __ ] hellmark I'm like give me
something give me something to work with
I love that yeah so look even more props
to you you could do it in any situation
awesome and then I'm also wondering too
was there any version of the script that
didn't have Anya dying or at least not
dying in this specific episode
[Music]
um
well I only got the kind of the final
draft to this the script for episode
seven was always kind of
that I don't know if the area versions
were different but the versions I got
they were all very similar yeah
interesting okay yeah I'm just trying to
reach anywhere here where she's somehow
still alive in any form uh but that's
the thing too is um
there is that moment we still get even
though we lose on you after episode
seven there's this big moment with the
fixed ballerina statue so how did you
interpret that whole thing is that a
sign from Anya I'm guessing to alanka
how did you see that
yeah I think it's
you know even when people die they're
never
really gone you always have the memories
of them and regardless of what you
believe and you know if there's an
afterlife or if there's
anything I I think it was this thing of
even though Anya's not physically there
anymore it should live on you know
through the stories and Sri Lanka's
memories she's never no one's ever I
think truly gone and their energy kind
of you know stays around some I don't I
don't know how to interpret this the
statue and I mean I hope for my for my
sake that I'm back but I don't know I
don't know no one will tell me anything
no I but I love that that's that's
beautiful you talk about that too that
that's that makes sense and
it's interesting too not only do you
play Anya here I think the fun thing for
you must have been getting to play other
characters and other people's stories in
the club so was there any characters you
particularly love playing or any fun
experience I said doing that
and I mean I loved the two Danish was so
much fun to film with with the lease um
I loved playing dinner too just because
I was I was there and I was like I'm
taking it too far um um
and Mike was just like behind the camera
and he was like yeah go again
I love it so you know everyone here is
already fall in love with you from this
show but I think what's really exciting
to know is to talk about announce that
you're going to be back in a Flanagan
Netflix project Fall of the House of
Usher so is there any teas or is it
gonna be crazy anything you can give us
about it
all I can say about that show is that it
is a bloodbath it is
like hard to the extreme if you love
you know and it still has all the good
things a better Mike Flanagan show but I
think two days it was going to be his
scariest most gruesome show I cannot I
cannot wait for it to come out because I
don't want to watch it oh that's amazing
so everybody get excited for that for
Ruth to be in that but in the meantime
keep watching The Midnight Club on
Netflix watch Ruth absolutely crush it
tell your friends about it family you
name it Ruth thank you so much for
joining me today and I hope to talk to
you in the future oh thank you that was
a fun interview thanks so much for
having me